former president george w bush speaks at
the 9 11 memorial in shanksville and
compares the january 6th rioters to the
911 terrorists joe biden's surrender to
al qaeda continues on 9 11 and democrats
turn to internacion warfare over their
3.5 trillion dollar budget buster i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by express vpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your reminder
customers are leaving companies like
verizon at t and t-mobile for a reason
they're leaving because they're paying
way too much for their cell phone
coverage they don't need to be paying
that much because verizon at t t-mobile
they have all these overpriced stores
and they have all these retail outlets
that cost money and so then they just
pass that cost directly onto you what if
you could get the same exact cell phone
coverage as you get from one of the big
providers but at a fraction of the cost
well you can that's pure talk usa
hundreds of thousands of smart families
are saving over eight hundred dollars a
year by switching to pure talk without
having to sacrifice coverage pure talks
on the exact same network is one of the
big three so what is your excuse i
already made the switch you can keep
your phone keep your number or get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids you can get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data for just 30 bucks a
month if you still want unlimited data
you can get that too and you'll still be
saving a lot over those other guys go to
puretalk.com enter your address to check
the coverage at your home or office and
then shop for the plan that's exactly
right for you you can even use their
savings calculator and see exactly how
much your family is going to save so
you'll know going in go to puretalk.com
enter promo code shapiro you will say 50
off your very first month of coverage
that's puretalk.com promo code shapiro
puretalk is simply smarter wireless
alrighty so
i will admit to a sneaking fondness for
president george w bush who was the
president for most of my late childhood
i was 16 years old when george w bush
took office in 2000
and in 2001 so i was 17
16 17 right on that ran on that cusp and
um and he was president obviously for
the next eight years so it was a quite
defining time in my thinking and i
remember defending george w bush from
all the people who called him bush
hitler and all the people who said that
he lied us into war and all the people
who suggested that he was a war criminal
and the main gripe that many people who
were george w bush fans had is that
george w bush spent eight years being a
very nice person he spent eight years
basically allowing everybody to attack
him with alacrity and never defending
himself it always felt as though there
were millions and millions of americans
who were out defending his policies and
he was not doing a good job of defending
his own policies and then he left and
when he left he was very unpopular
because of the economic downturn and he
essentially disappeared for years from
the american political scene because
like his father he believed that
ex-presidents shouldn't really be seen
and they really shouldn't be heard they
should just sort of go away and allow
their successors to do what they're
going to do but then george w bush
started cropping up in places from time
to time you would see him doing an ad
campaign with the clintons and the
obamas you'd see him hobnobbing with
michelle obama and every time he spoke
out politically it seemed like he was
doing so in order to ding the right it
seemed as though he would never speak
out with regard to the left because that
would have been insulting but he would
speak out about ted cruz for example or
he would speak out about black lives
matter he put out a statement last year
that was very sympathetic toward black
lives matter and now george w bush
showed up at the 911 memorial in
shanksville pennsylvania to commemorate
the 20th anniversary
of 9 11. and i think that george w bush
represents a certain sort of delusional
conciliatory attitude that some
establishment republicans still have
with regard to politics now i think that
you can have
worthwhile useful discussions with
people on the opposite side of the
political aisle i do it all the time
right on our sunday special we routinely
invite people who are not of my
political thinking and we have long-form
discussions about that i may do that
more than anybody else on the right i
appear on shows where people disagree
with me pretty frequently and i think
it's important to do so but to pretend
that we are at a level of unity in
american politics where we simply are
not is to mistake the moment it is to
ignore where we are in american politics
and frankly where we have been for a
very long time because the truth is that
american politics was very broken even
during the bush era i know that we're
supposed to look back and think that the
world began spinning during the
trump era or during the obama era the
reality is it did not take long after 9
11 for the left immediately to swivel
and start beating george w bush with a
hammer it did not take long for hillary
clinton to appear on the floor of the
senate saying what did bush know and
when did he know it about 9 11. the
implication being that the bush
administration had ignored the
intelligence that would have prevented
911 for example it did not take long for
howard dean to start talking about how
george w bush was essentially a war
criminal it did not take very long for
the democratic media to try to suggest
that george w bush was a liar that he
was a fool that he was attempting to
elias into war in iraq that he was a war
monger and all the rest right that he
had gotten us stuck in a quagmire that
was the word of the day in 2003. and
george philly bush never really seemed
to understand what had happened i think
after 9 11 he was still working in the
911 mode because there was a
transformative moment for just a moment
in american politics it's the only time
i can remember in my entire lifetime
after 9 11 there was a feeling among
americans that yes actually there is an
existential enemy out there and that
enemy is not us and we we may not like
our neighbors we may think that the
people who disagree with us on politics
and america have it wrong but there is a
difference in kind between the guy who
lives down the street and disagrees with
you about tax law and the person who is
attempting to fly a plane into a
building
resulting in 3 000 american deaths and
the pictures of human beings jumping to
their death from the 85th story of the
world trade center
right there's a difference in kind for a
brief moment in america there was a
feeling like okay we're unified as a
country and it went away almost
immediately it went away very very very
quickly
and i don't think that george w bush
ever really took stock of that i think
he's always been longing for that moment
again i understand it i understand the
nostalgia for that moment but to pretend
that that is the underlying reality of
america right now that when you get
right down to it we still are all
friends we still all agree we still are
all on the same page i think ignores how
much has changed over the course of the
last 20 years i think it's why we are in
such a dire situation it's why i've
written
three separate books now about why it
seems like our unifying principles are
coming apart principles that we actually
did sort of commonly hold even in 2000
right principles about the general rule
of government in american life it was
bill clinton who was saying in the 1990s
that the era of big government was over
principles that we held about the
necessity for treating other human
beings as individuals it was bill
clinton when 1992 was having a sister
soldier moment meaning he was literally
saying to people that the sort of equity
talk you hear from the left the racial
talk that you hear from left today and
is celebrated by the white house was
then rejected by the democratic party
the the color blind notions that martin
luther king jr was was promoting those
notions had taken predominance in
american life as of 2000 that is not the
case in america in 2021 there's a very
serious rift in american life and in
american philosophy and in american
politics
and that's a rift in values and i don't
think george w bush really understands
that and so what that ends with is
george w bush
at the 9 11 memorial
saying
something that i think it ends up he's
trying to be unifying and it ends up
being divisive because he doesn't
understand the nature of modern america
and it's this disconnect between
establishment politicians and people who
are sort of in the elite codery of of
american life it's the disconnect
between those folks and the rest of
america that leads to the rise of
populism on both the left and the right
because at the top of the chain there
are people who are like yeah we
understand that politics is really sort
of just rock'em sock and robots it's all
just a game it's it's sort of as though
if you're a fan of a baseball team and
you watch the players on the field you
want them to be competitive with each
other because you understand that
something is at stake and then
somebody hits a home run it ends the
game and the other guys go out there and
they're giving each other hugs they're
out for drinks that night as a fan
you're like why are you doing that
well politically speaking it's sort of
the same thing except in baseball you
understand okay well they're players you
know it's still a game politics is
really not a game politics is deadly
serious business when you're talking
about how you impact 300 million
american lives okay so we'll get to what
george w bush actually said at
shanksville in just one second first
let us talk for just one moment about
the fact that if you run a business you
need to keep hr issues first and
foremost in your mind right as your
business grows you think you really
don't need to think about hr it's just
kind of an afterthought wrong this needs
to become a key component of what you do
and bambi can help make that happen hr
manager salaries are not cheap they
average 70 000 bucks a year bambi is
spelled b-a-m-b-e-e it was created
specifically for small business you can
get a dedicated hr manager craft hr
policy and maintain your compliance all
for just 99 bucks a month
with bambi you can change hr from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength your dedicated hr manager is
available by phone email or real-time
chat
from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day-to-day all for just 99
bucks a month they're month-to-month no
hidden fees you can cancel any time you
didn't start your business because you
wanted to spend time on hr compliance
let bambi help get your free hr audit
today go to bambi.com shapiro right now
schedule your free hr audit that's
bambi.com
shapiro spell b-a-m to the b-e-e dot com
shapiro go check them out right now okay
so george w bush goes to the 9 11
memorial in shanksville and he proceeds
to say some very very nice things and
then he says one thing that ends up
being the headline of course because he
was trying to say something unifying and
um he failed so he starts off by talking
about how americans when we are forced
together are exceptional which of course
is true
20 years ago terrorists chose a random
group of americans on a routine flight
to be collateral damage in a spectacular
act of terror
the 33 passengers and seven crew of
flight 93
could have been any group of citizens
selected by fate
in a sense
they stood in for us all
the terrorists soon discovered that a
random group of americans is an
exceptional group of people
facing an impossible circumstance
they comforted their loved ones by phone
each other for action
and defeated the designs of evil
okay and all of that was true and this
is the world that george w bush i think
wishes to occupy frankly it's a world i
wish to occupy as well i mean i i think
that what happened on flight 93 is a
great indicator of what americans are
when put to the test george w bush
continued along these lines and um he
talked a little bit about the men and
women who have served in harm's way and
you start to see the first inklings here
of why the bush presidency
which again i think that bush in many
ways is a man of principle but the bush
presidency was a disappointing failure
in many ways and i think one of the
reasons was because again he he just did
not defend his own policies he did not
defend what he was doing so here he was
it's 20 years later we've now
surrendered in afghanistan to the very
people who perpetrated 9 11. and george
w bush has had not a word to say about
that really he said not one word about
the policy he's he sat aside well
joe biden surrendered the entire country
back to the exact people who did 9 11. i
mean like the exact people who did 911
he's had nothing to say about that
instead he has sort of comforting words
for the for the members of the military
which is fine but where is he when it
comes to the actual serious questions of
policy let me speak directly to veterans
and people in uniform
the cause you pursued at the call of
duty is the noblest america has to offer
you have shielded your fellow citizens
from danger
you have defended the beliefs of your
country
and advance the rights of the
downtrodden
you have been the face of hope
and mercy in dark places
you have been a force for good in the
world
nothing that has followed
nothing
can tarnish your honor
or diminish your accomplishments
to you and to the honored dead
our country is forever grateful
has a rather oblique critique of the
biden foreign policy in afghanistan okay
so if you're gonna do a unity speech
then what you really need to talk about
are unifying principles right you need
to talk about what brings america
together and georgia will be bush did
many of those things
in that speech
but if you're going to critique then the
critique has to be pointed and it has to
be specific
or at least it has to be broad enough to
encompass the big problems in american
society
people on the right i think responded
with the trump era because of the obama
ear but also because of the bush era as
we'll see in just one second because
here is george w bush this is the clip
that made all the headlines right it
wasn't all of the talk about unity it
wasn't all the talk about bringing
americans together
it was this line from george w bush that
brought all the commentary this is the
line where he compares the january 6th
rioters to the 911 hijackers
we have seen growing evidence
that the dangers to our country can come
not only across
borders but from violence that gathers
within
there is little cultural overlap between
violent extremists abroad and violent
extremists at home
but then there's disdainful pluralism
in their disregard for human life
in their determination to defile
national symbols
they are children of the same foul
spirit
and it is our continuing duty to
confront them
okay so everybody took this as a
critique of the
one six rioters
now it's possible to read it as a
broader critique than that right that
he's talking about white supremacists or
that he's talking about antifa or that
he's talking about black lives matter
the problem is of course that he
released a statement in favor of black
lives matter last june
in which he talked about systemic
american racism and all the rest of the
left-wing buzzwords and it is also
possible to say that the 1-6 rioters did
something evil i have said that
many many times i think that storming
the capitol building on the basis of a
falsehood
both that the election was stolen and
that the election results were capable
of being overturned after having been
certified at the state level that was
all a lie that was not true
and they stormed the capitol building
to compare those people still to the 911
hijackers who literally murdered three
thousand americans the only american who
was actually killed at the capitol on
one six like died at the capitol on one
six because of direct action by another
human being the only person who actually
died because of that was ashley babbitt
right who was shot at the capitol and
she was one of the rioters
okay that that is not remotely the same
thing as the 911 hijackers either in
their aims i mean the goal of the 911
hijackers was to completely overthrow
the the system of the united states not
because of a quote unquote
stolen election or anything like that
but because they didn't believe in
elections they believe in full-on sharia
law right they wanted the kind of
governance that you see in afghanistan
the comparison fails on nearly every
level but what's more important is i
think george w bush thought that he was
saying something unifying here right
which is that attacks on american
institutions and attacks on american
principles are unacceptable across the
board but the feeling that people get on
the right is that he doesn't mean it
across the board and by the way that was
the feeling on the left as well because
if the left thought that he meant that
across the board if they thought that he
equally meant the one six rioters and
the people who burned down american
cities last summer resulting in at least
five billion dollars in property damage
about two billion dollars of insured
they that that if they felt that he was
applying that to antifa with the same
sort of alacrity that he was applying
that to white supremacists
then there might be some sort of unity
but they don't feel like that and
neither is the left and the reason you
can tell the left doesn't feel like that
is because they were giving him the
strange new respect treatment and this
is what's truly going after eight years
of defending george w bush in his
policies
after eight years of going to political
battle
for the bush administration
on behalf of many of their policies
right i disagreed with george w bush a
lot and sometimes i'd critique him but
if you go back and read my columns i was
i defended many of george w bush's big
moves when he wouldn't defend himself
after eight years of that to feel as
though the ex-president of the united
states who you defended
only emerges to critique one side of the
political aisle even if that side
deserves critique even if those radicals
deserve critique but he is not
attempting to critique everybody he's
only critiquing a certain group
a certain radical subsection of a
movement as opposed to you know the
people who actually destroyed his
presidency at every point
and then to receive the strange respect
from the same people who spent eight
years declaring him a war monger and a
bad human being that's how you get trump
that's how you get trump and you deserve
trump
right that's how it comes to that
and you can see the left celebrating
bush right you have joe biden who says
that you know bush made a great speech
about who we are why do you think joe
biden is celebrating george w bush
he spent years ripping on george w bush
in 2008 when biden was running alongside
barack obama he labeled john mccain a
continuation of the horrible the
horrific bush era that was the main line
george lily bush was so bad and john
mccain will be more of that
i mean joe biden spent years trashing
george w bush but now he's very happy
with george w bush which makes you think
has joe biden changed or
is george w bush just paying homage to a
delusional conciliation that does not
exist in american politics here's here's
joe biden
i thought that president bush made a
really good speech today
genuinely good speech
about who we are where we're not
the core of who we are
is not divided
the core of who we are is not divided
says this is the part where again
i think bush is misreading the situation
and i think a lot of the right-wing
establishment the con so-called this
conservative establishment is misreading
the moment
i'll explain more of this in just one
second because
when joe biden said
that he was trying to generate unity
when he was inaugurated i said at the
time
we still have to define what he means by
unity by unity does he mean they were
going to attempt to come together around
common principles and leave people alone
let them live their lives or by unity
does he mean you shut the hell up and i
will tell you what to do and it is
extremely obvious at this point that joe
biden means the latter and if george w
bush means the former then unity does
not mean the same thing to george w bush
that it means to joe biden
and yet george w bush is using the exact
same language which is a dangerous thing
to do it obscures clarity it makes
things opaque and not only that it
grants weapons to the people who
actually wish to infringe upon your
freedoms each and every day and divide
americans each and every day okay so as
you see joe biden is praising george w
bush for the unity speech but he's
really praising him because he believes
that george w bush is attacking
people
purportedly of the right but never
anybody
on the left right this is what unity
means to people
of joe biden's ilk
unity means we are right and you are
wrong and you shut up and if you
disagree
there's no unity that's what joe biden
means and i don't take seriously that
joe biden is particularly upset about
january 6th because january 6 is worse
in kind than the riots we saw that
wrecked the cities across the summer and
have led to a radically exacerbated
murder rate in every major city in
america i just don't believe that he he
even believes that
i think that he believes that people who
agree with his agenda are basically good
and people who disagree with his agenda
are basically bad
that is not a unifying perspective
kamala harris is doing the same thing
right you're granting this is why i'm
very frustrated with with george w
bush's speech not because of the
critique of one sex but because of the
inability to
to know and understand
that radicalism on all sides of all
aisles is a major major problem when you
only critique one side of the aisle and
then you say that unity is in the offing
you are incorrect
all you are doing is granting favor to
people who have actively promoted the
disunity
if you're not willing to condemn all of
the bad things you're only willing to
condemn some of the bad things you're
fomenting others of the bad things the
left knows this which is why they were
using bush's speech over the weekend
here's kamala harris doing the same
thing calling for unity this is
absolutely galling stuff coming from
kamala harris
i mean it's
here she is calling for unity
unity is imperative
in america
it is essential to our shared prosperity
to our national security
and to our standing in the world
and by unity i don't mean uniformity
we had differences of opinion in 2001
as we do
in 2021
and i believe that in america
our diversity
is our strength
she's a liar when she says that she
doesn't believe that unity is uniformity
no she 100 does
she does not believe in diversity of
opinion in any serious way
you can look at her legislative record
on this it is pretty clear this is not a
person who deeply cares about diversity
of opinion there's a person who's part
of an administration that is attacking
other americans for diversity of opinion
yet the same thing from media you got
jim acosta doing the same thing what
happened to our unity what happened
we didn't just become divided
we let hate into our hearts
for each other
there was an expression used after 9 11
all gave some some gave all
we don't really do that anymore
some of us don't want to give anything
at all
we live in separate worlds now
we don't agree on the same facts anymore
we can't even agree on wearing masks or
getting vaccinated to end this pandemic
why isn't there unity because of you
people who won't mask after being
vaccinated yeah i wonder why there's not
unity we're gonna get into that in a
second because that is the crux of the
matter why isn't there the unity we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that now is
not a great time to go to the auto parts
store because never is a great time to
go to the auto parts store right you
wait in line you finally get to the
front of the line when you finally do
get the front to the front of the line
they ask a bunch of questions and then
they're like yeah man we don't have that
part we're gonna order it you're like
how long does that take like two weeks i
don't have two weeks i mean i
my car doesn't work like well i can't
make it faster or brawl you're gonna
have to come back or you could just go
online and do it yourself rockauto.com
it's much easier they always offer the
lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like the airlines do why spend
up to twice as much for the same parts
furthermore prices at rockauto.com are
always the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers their family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about xbox so they know that we sent you
go to rockauto.com right now and get the
parts that you need today rockauto.com
and again write your appearance on that
how did you hear about usbox so they
know that we sent you all right so
georgetown bush calls for unity and in
the process of calling for unity he
basically name checks the one six
rioters but nothing else right that is
where he's putting his his sole focus
which is inherently unifying because it
turns out that there are a lot of
threads in the fabric of america that
are being torn asunder many of them by
the leadership of the united states
which george w bush has studiously
ignored as long as it is coming from the
left since 2008. and this is coming from
somebody who uh voted for george i was
old enough to vote in 2000 i voted for
george w bush in 2004 and supported much
of his agenda
it is extremely frustrating and it's
extremely frustrating to watch people
who ripped him and wrecked his
presidency now use george w bush and his
statement as a tool to wield on behalf
of an inherently ununifying agenda
disunifying agenda you've got kamala
harris saying that she also believes in
unity and jim acosta's saying he
believes in unity no you don't you're
liars
you absolutely do not i know you don't
because last summer kamal harris was
backing rioters last summer kamala
harris was tweeting out about how we
could actually bail out rioters in
minneapolis you remember her famous
tweet on this her infamous tweet on this
in which she tweeted out if you're able
to chip in now to the minnesota freedom
fund to help post bail for those
protesting on the ground in minnesota
the people in jail were not protesters
they were rioters
but don't worry she's not for uniformity
she's only for unity
you know joe biden is like ah it's a
great speech by by it's time for us to
come together it's time for last week he
was labeling the unvaccinated the worst
among us you never mind if there by the
way no exceptions for natural immunity
no exceptions for other health
conditions if you're unvaccinated you're
a bad person according to joe biden and
he's going to lecture you about it but
he's for unity you see
my message to unvaccinated americans is
this
what more is there to wait for
what more do you need to see
we've made vaccinations free
safe and convenient
the vaccine is fda approval
over 200 million americans have gotten
at least one shot
we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us
that's that's captain unity over there
right the man who's bringing us all
together the person with whom george w
bush is meeting across the table to talk
about unity you have the media jim
acosta one of the most divisive media
figures of the last several years out
there talking about how we can't even
have unity why can't we have unity like
we had in 911 we can't even have unity
about masking right because there are
serious questions to be asked about the
necessity of masking in a time when
every american adult has the ability to
go get vaccinated right there are
serious data questions to be asked about
the efficacy of particular types of
masks and their studies that demonstrate
the cloth masks against the delta
variant are not particularly effective
for example but according to jim acosta
if you don't do what he wants you to do
you are threatening unity
and this is the the shtick of the left
and george shelley bush played right
into it the stick of the left is
that unity is offered by monopoly and if
you are a person who exists outside of
the monopoly then you have now created
two polls which means polarization
polarization is a simple result
according to the left of your failure to
agree with them
at the same media who are decrying lack
of unity on 9 11 spent most of 9 11
trying to jab her about how coveted was
like 9 11 code is not like 9 11.
i mean it's certainly not it's not like
9 11 in the sense that you guys won't
even blame the people who are
responsible namely the chinese
government but not only that
code is not like 911 because it's hit
everywhere it's a global pandemic and
yet the left kept saying over and over
that it was like 9 11. the implication
being that people who refuse to do what
we want are like the terrorists that is
the implication
msnbc chuck todd over the weekend
compared 911 to cova this is not a
comparison
i guess the best way to look at the two
battles that that the country engaged in
we had an outside invader in al qaeda
and so we were able to
unite we had a common enemy with coven
this invisible enemy were not able to do
it and you know willie thinking about
this all week when you actually
sadly you look at the arc of
of american
history
polarization in some ways is more common
than us coming together
i mean and then you get from nicole
wallace that it's like 9 11 every couple
of days covered no it is not it is like
a health problem that is killing a lot
of people
by the way health problems which we have
a solution namely go get yourself
vaccinated if you don't want to then you
bear the consequences of that that's not
like 911 in any way shape or form that's
like if on 911 you had the option to
leave the building before
okay that is not the same thing at all
and also it's as though the attackers on
9 11
had no actual will or agenda because
viruses don't but here's nicole wallace
making that absurd comparison again the
implication being that the people who
refuse to go along with the agenda here
are the ones who are leading to disunity
i i think there are so many parallels to
how much more difficult it is to do any
of the things that anyone who has spoken
today has done to call the country to a
higher purpose
you've got politicians and prominent
folks in in the media um
outraged by steps that a a president not
too many presidents after the one we
heard from today would try to save his
country from an unthinkable death toll i
mean as many people die every two days
has died on september 11th in this
country who don't have to die
and yet there's no unity no unity no
unity why isn't there unity
we all know why there's no unity and
it's because the basic principles that
you see unite the united states have
gone the way of their otobird they were
barely there even when bush was
president in fact many of them crumbled
while bush was president
and this is what's so frustrating i
think to so many people on the right
watching george w bush's speech and
looking at many in the republican
establishment who seem
to feel the same way as george w bush
that unity is just around the corner if
only i condemn this specific set of
people but not broadly speaking all
people who commit these sorts of sins
like that it's playing right into the
hands of people who actively use uni
unity as a as a guise
for
a uniformity
okay and again i do find a calling that
george w bush apparently only emerges to
critique the the perspectives of people
he purports to see as on the right right
like that that that is is particularly
galling to me especially when you have
the president of the united states who
just destroyed george w bush's legacy in
afghanistan let's be frank about this
george w bush went into afghanistan with
uniformity of purpose there was
uniformity one member of congress voted
against it
okay everyone wanted to go into
afghanistan
even barack obama in 2008 was calling it
the good war in 2008.
and joe biden decided to pull out and
hand the country directly back to the
taliban and then on the 20th anniversary
of 9 11 he was talking about why he was
right to do so and talking about and
setting up these false binaries where i
mean it's unbelievable he's
in places like shanksville he's meeting
with he's meeting with first responders
and he's talking about how you know we
really have to be circumspect in how we
fight al qaeda
if you had told anybody that we were
going to spend
300 million bucks a day for 20 years to
try to unite the country
after we got bin laden
after
al-qaeda was wiped out there
can i al-qaeda come back yeah but guess
what it's already back other places
what's the strategy
every place where qaeda is we're going
to invade and have troops stay there
come on
well no the strategy is everywhere al
qaeda is we're going to go on and we're
going to kill them i mean i thought that
was literally the point of the war on
terror
the entire point of it that any place
they were they were using as a base who
threatened the united states we were
going to go in and kill them that was
the basic idea of the war on terror
okay so all of this leads to trump
because trump isn't having this right
you want to know why trump is durable in
the republican imagination the reason
trump is durable in the republican
imagination is because trump is not
having any of this bullcrap
my way or the highway unity
he's not going to sit around and pretend
that joe biden is a unifying figure he's
not going to make patty cake with the
obamas who are highly polarizing figures
in american political life
he is not going to sit around and
pretend that joe biden is some sort of
figure figure of great magnanimity who
simply wants us all to come together
and so well normally it is sort of
considered uncouth on 9 11 to talk about
the failures of a of an administration
currently in power it becomes a lot less
uncouth when you have an entire
administration that has directed itself
to destroying the purpose of the
american response to 9 11. so when trump
just doesn't operate inside the same
sphere as the republican establishment
the republican establishment is still
making nice and doing shoulder massages
with the people who are using unity as a
club and trump's like i'm just not going
to play that game
you wonder why he's popular at the
republican base still that is the reason
he's popular at the republican base
still now he's not the only one who can
do this there are other people on the
right who are doing this as well
you don't know why ron desantis in
florida is popular at the republican
base it's because he does this with
regard to covet in the media all the
time but the reason that trump is
popular with the republican base is he
is not going to pretend that he and joe
biden are on the same page when it comes
to things like afghanistan like it is
somewhat mad again it is maddening to me
that joe biden who spent years backing
the afghanistan campaign under george w
bush but then simultaneously undermined
bush at every available turn 20 years
later destroys what's going on in
afghanistan by the way everything going
on with kovid everything going on with
the budget it is all an attempt to
distract from his failure in afghanistan
that is what this is it's why he's
trying to ram it through
and trump wasn't having any of that so
his presidential message oh it's not
presidential why couldn't he be
presidential like bush
maybe because he's being realistic
unlike bush here was trump yesterday
it is also a sad time for the way our
war on those that did such harm to our
country ended last week
the loss of 13 great warriors and the
many more who were wounded
should never have happened the leader of
our country was made to look like a fool
and that can never be allowed to happen
it was caused by bad planning incredible
weakness and leaders who truly didn't
understand what was happening this is
the 20th year of this war
and should have been a year of victory
and honor and strength
instead joe biden and his inept
administration surrendered in defeat
okay not only is he not wrong he is
correct about what time it is as they
say
is correct that we don't live in a world
where unity of purpose is a thing and
anybody on the left or on the right who
tells you the unity of purpose in
america is still a thing
is missing the game they are missing the
game that is being played
okay in afghanistan right now the
taliban started flying their flag over
the presidential palace in kabul on the
day of the 20th anniversary of 9 11. the
white banner with the shahada that's the
testimony written across it was raised
at an 11 a.m ceremony on saturday to
mark the beginning of the work for the
taliban's caretaker government
the taliban did not issue a formal
statement on the anniversary of the
al-qaeda terrorist attacks that procl
that preluded them being driven from
power 20 years earlier but the image of
the flag was a stunning reminder of
course
meanwhile
the
biden administration it now turns out on
their way out of afghanistan remember
they had this quote-unquote successful
drone attack to go after the isis
members who
perpetrated that terror attack that
killed 13 americans well it turns out in
all likelihood according to the new york
times they did in fact kill an afghan
translator and members of his family
but they had no idea who they were
hitting
is that unity
the taliban are going around literally
beating women in the streets
there's video of it emerging
is that unity women are now in hiding
all over afghanistan and we're supposed
to pretend that unity is just it's just
under the surface if only we could get
at it if only and we're supposed to
pretend that we don't know the reasons
for the disunity we know the reasons for
the disunity
don't don't gaslight the american people
by telling them
that we are all in favor of unity you
are not
you are not the folks on the left are on
the hard left and in the bite
administration are not in favor of unity
they don't want to explain what they are
doing politically they don't want to
explain why their policies are right
they don't want to brook dissent
they want to use the powers of the
federal government to ram through
anything that they can without regard
for the constitutional process they want
to do it in top down fashion
they want to completely rewrite the
american national bargain and they want
to castigate all of their opponents as
inherently polarizing for things like
really you're telling me i need to mask
up my five-year-old
the answer there is no
which is why again
you want trump you're gonna get more of
them this is how you're gonna get more
trump
it will get to the disunifying
democratic budget campaign this is what
they're pushing forward to it's breaking
budget campaign in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that now is an
excellent time to refinance at your home
if you could spend a few hours over a
few weeks and save yourself up to 12 000
bucks a year you'd do that right of
course you would i mean i would as well
an extra 12 000 bucks here it's a lot of
money it's a significant dent in your
debt right it's an opportunity that
currently exists when you refinance your
mortgage you've just got to call
american financing america's home for
home loans talk with an expert mortgage
consultant you can learn about custom
loans that might fit your budget better
no pressure no obligation no upfront or
hidden fees
just a simple conversation around ways
you can save up to a thousand dollars a
month and it only takes a 10 minute call
to get started so what exactly are you
waiting for you can pre-qualify for free
at 866-721-3300
3300 or you can apply online at
americanfinancing.net and mls 182 334
nmls consumer access dot or go check
them out again 866 721 3300 that is
one 866
three hundred or check them out at
americanfinancing.net and see what kind
of deal you can get on refinancing that
home mortgage with rates this low you
really can't afford not to check them
out americanfinancing.net
already as the legacy media continues to
spread their propaganda in these really
difficult times it is important you have
a source you can trust that is why we
launched morning wire it's the daily
morning news show dedicated to bringing
you everything you need to know without
any spin or hidden agenda it's the only
daily podcast that values your time and
the truth while we're working overtime
to make sure fact based news still has a
platform we need your help to keep
morning wire trending toward number one
so please subscribe and start listening
right now to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcast and leave a five star view if
you like what you hear
also you may have noticed that what is
happening in america right now is the
antithesis of what the founders sought
the president of the united states has
decided to go the authoritarian route
and mandate vaccines for all businesses
with over 100 employees or testing of
all employees or you've got to fire the
employees that includes all of us here
at the daily wire they're doing this not
through the legislative process not
through the states they're doing this
through osha
and this is just administrative
bureaucratic dictatorship we are not
going to stand for that we're going to
fight the mandate for our employees for
our freedom and for you i'm pro-vaccine
i'm anti-these mandates i think they are
a direct encroachment a federal
encroachment on the constitutional order
we're pretty fired up about it that's
why you should tune in to catch an
all-new episode discussing what's
happening and how we fight back at
backstage tomorrow with me jeremy boring
michael knowles matt walsh and andrew
clavin in streams tomorrow 7 00 p.m
eastern 6 p.m central on dailywire.com
and on our youtube channel dailywire
don't miss it you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile these so-called unification
democrats they're just seeking unity
they love diversity of opinion i mean
it's just what they love they're seeking
to ram through a world-breaking 3.5
trillion dollar budget buster in the
middle of a divisive news cycle with
inflation at the highest rate for
businesses since 2010
according to the bureau of labor
statistics the producer price index
which monitors changes in input prices
for businesses and other domestic
producers rose at 0.7 percent in august
slightly beating the 0.6 rate predicted
by economists inflation for businesses
has now reached a year-over-year rate of
8.3 that's the metric's highest level
since
2010. okay and it's not just rising
inflation it is also an economy that is
pretty much crapping out as you will
recall joe biden's employment statistics
have been pretty dire he was supposed to
hit 780 000 new jobs last month he had
instead about 235 000 new jobs last
month but democrats are pushing forward
with their budget plan anyway
this is a budget plan that is as the new
york times described it cradle to grave
here is what is in this 3.5 trillion
plant remember this is on top of the 1.9
trillion dollars we spent earlier this
year and the
1.2 trillion 1.1 trillion dollars in
these so-called infrastructure
bipartisan bill
so that means that if these things were
all to pass this year you'd be talking
about a minimum of 6.5 trillion dollars
spent in this year
right or at least passed in this year
and spent over the next few years
because there will be more money spent
next year
so what exactly is in this package well
it would be
including paid family and medical leave
subsidized child care an extension of
the expanded child tax credit universal
pre-k for three and four-year-olds
despite the failures of head start two
years of tuition at free community
college it would also provide green
cards to millions of immigrants you may
have noticed that that has nothing to do
with the budget doesn't matter democrats
are going to shovel that crap in there
as well as according to the wall street
journal it would also extend
expanded aca subsidies right obamacare
subsidies approved earlier this year in
the covet 19 aid package so we're just
going to continue to expand emergency
measures that were taken during covet 19
the plan would broaden medicare benefits
to cover now dental vision and hearing
that would aim to reduce the cost of
prescription drugs by allowing medicare
to negotiate prices among other steps
allowing medicare to negotiate prices of
course destroys all of the incentives
for pharmaceutical companies to develop
drugs in the united states in the first
place also democrats are proposing a
series of ideas including tax credits
for clean energy investments
and a plan resembling a clean
electricity standard aimed at reducing
carbon emissions in the electricity
sector by 80 percent also democrats are
proposing polluter import fees
so how exactly are democrats going to
pay for all of this so they released a
plan yesterday
explaining how they are going to pay for
all of this and the answer is they're
going to raise taxes in a radical
fashion that we have not seen it for
decades the house democrats are now
proposing a plan
for 2.9 trillion dollars in new taxes
notice that even though they're raising
2.9 trillion dollars in new taxes we're
spending as i said 6.5 trillion dollars
approved in this year alone so it still
doesn't pay for any of this nonsense
okay what exactly are they going to do
well they're going to increase the top
tax rate on americans earning over 435
000 a year from 37 to 39.6 percent also
there's going to be a 3
surcharge on top of that
and then there's going to be an niit
right which is a surcharge on top of
that so the actual top tax bracket would
go to 46
before any state taxes were actually
applied meaning that the actual state
tax for people in the top income bracket
in say california would be nearly 60
on income
it also calls for a new corporate tax
rate of 26.5 for large profitable
businesses up from the current rate of
21 this would put our corporate tax rate
above china's
so it'll be fun to watch all of the um
businesses rush and scurry for the exits
and watch the job loss that comes along
with that
many items in the new draft scale back
the more ambitious tax increases stopped
by biden earlier this year but the ideas
taken together amount to a significant
unwinding of the tax cuts enacted by
republicans
the draft tax also included some
surprises
including an expected increase in the
capital gains rate paid by investors to
so basically you paid taxes on your
income you then took that income and you
put it in the stock market now they're
going to tax any capital gains that you
make from the stock market at 25
which of course is going to hurt a lot
of people who have say pensions in the
stock market
biden's plan originally suggested
approximately doubling the capital gains
tax rate
also they're as i say going to have that
new sur tax on quote unquote high income
individuals
democrats are floating a tiered system
for the corporate tax rate only firms
with incomes above 5 million bucks would
pay the new 26.5 rate
which of course is most businesses that
hire a significant number of people in
the united states
also the proposal is going after new
tobacco taxes so remember he said he was
he was not going to raise taxes on
people who were poor yeah that's not
true tobacco and nicotine taxes are
directed at poor people because poor
people in the united states
disproportionately smoke
that proposal calls for increasing taxes
on tobacco and nicotine by roughly 100
billion dollars while also raising 16
billion from changing rules to quote
treat cryptocurrency the same as other
financial instruments so they're going
to crack down on cryptocurrency of
course they are they have to crack down
on cryptocurrency the reason they're
cracking down on crypto is because
crypto is a way for people to escape the
predations of the federal government
inflating its own currency
and the next step presumably will be for
the federal government to create a fed
coin right to create its own sort of
digital currency and then
the federal government will take its
benefits and it will directly deposit
them into your bank account and then
will charge you a negative interest rate
to so they'll just force you to spend it
basically you'll do fiscal policy
directly into your bank account right
that is the next step with a vet coin
so in order to do that they have to kill
crypto that is that is their actual goal
here
so this is the house democrats tax plan
if democrats get their way they're going
to radically increase taxes and that
will have a dire effect on the economy
meanwhile democrats are hurtling toward
a debt ceiling fight
it turns out there are some rank and
file democrats who are not going to
vote in crete for increasing the debt
ceiling unless they get a bigger
spending bill
according to politico democrats
threadbare majorities in congress are
leaving the party with little time to
wriggle out of a dangerous economic
morass that could overwhelm other
priorities from voting rights to tax
increases on the wealthy to a sweeping
expansion of the social safety net
top democrats say they have a plan but
they don't want to talk about it talk
about it yet government funding runs out
in 18 days according to politico the
biden administration says the debt
ceiling must be raised shortly after
that senate republicans say that they
are not voting for it
the house also doesn't come back until
september 20th so this means that you're
going to see the progressives now try to
hold up the quote-unquote bipartisan
infrastructure plan in order to get the
3.5 trillion plan this is turned into a
fight between the progressive wing and
joe manchin joe manchin yesterday said
to his credit he's not going to support
this 3.5 trillion dollar boondoggle the
realistic number's more like 1.5
trillion dollars
he's moving quote full speed ahead with
this package will he have your vote and
that's fine he can't he will not have my
vote on 3.5 and chuck knows that but
what's the overall number for the budget
bill i think that you're going to have
to look at it and find out what you're
able to do through a reasonably
responsible way so then how do you know
that it's not three point five it's
going to be at one one and a half we
don't know where it's going to be so you
think ballpark one one it's not going to
be at three and a half i can assure you
meanwhile bernie sanders going directly
after joe manchin and trying to uh
trying to take him out here's bernie
sanders saying well if you won't pass
our 3.5 trillion dollar plan then uh
we're not going to pass your one point
your 1.1 trillion dollar infrastructure
bill that's bipartisan
your colleague joe manchin just
explicitly told me repeatedly he will
not support your 3.5 trillion dollar
reconciliation bill he wants to see
something more in the ballpark of 1.5
trillion is that acceptable to you
no it's absolutely not acceptable to me
i don't think it's acceptable to the
president to the american people or the
overwhelming majority of the people in
the democratic caucus
okay so that infighting will be
fascinating to watch but again it is
indicative of the fact that the
progressive wing of the democratic party
which now has control over the
democratic party is moving radically to
the left so calls for unity with that
sort of move
are i think
overstated to say the very very least
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show today he discusses the uk
reversing plans for vaccine passports
you can hear more details about that
story over on michael's show that's
available right now i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
a new study shows that teen boys are 6.1
times as likely to face danger from the
vaccine as from kovid an ex-special
forces dude beats up a chick to wild
applause and george w bush compares the
horn guy at the capitol to al-qaeda
terrorists check it out on the michael
knolls show